that's
something i probably should say also
because it's something that i think is
really important for aspiring
screenwriters which is that
your first draft is nothing more
than you i usually say vomiting up
these ideas that are in your head and
getting them out of your head and onto
paper or onto your
your screen
trying to make a perfect first draft is
a waste of your time
because that's not what first drafts are
for first drafts are
for for my this is my opinion you know
there are other you know
screenwriters who might disagree but but
i think it's just about it's like get it
out
get it out of there because you can't
look at it objectively
unless you can look at it
you know what i mean it's all running
around up in here but unless you get it
out and look at it and then you can
really
tell if something is working or where
there might be a gigantic hole or
whatever
the the second draft is way more
important than the first draft
because the second draft is where you
can then
start to chip away or
add or you know like it's almost like if
it was a sculpture
sure are you creating an outline before
you do this messy first draft okay so
it's like you're making this
this bust or whatever you know this like
you know mozart
and you're in you're you're gonna but
it's just this lump of clay or whatever
but you kind of know okay well i know
his head's gonna be here and we're gonna
do his vest and all you know these
different things
right you're not just like here let's
try this you have a plan
i yeah i always have a plan um
i might not the third
the third part i almost said third act
and that's something that i don't always
agree with i don't always agree with the
first second and third act kind of thing
right it's i i i think that if you if
uh like the save the cat mentality um
which is that you know everything's so
codified that this has to happen here
and this has to happen here and this has
to happen here
i think that's the danger of that is it
could stifle
imagination um but
when i do an outline um
i don't necessarily fill in that
last part the ending yeah
because i want because so many things
can happen along that road
of getting to that part that
i i like to leave it i mean i've sort of
of course i have some idea of how it's
going to end
but i don't want to i don't want to put
in too many details because i want to
see
if if the ending will find itself almost
organically
i trust in that it it will it will find
its way as we get closer
so so yes i do have an idea of what that
ending is going to be
um but i don't want it to be i
i don't want it stamped and solid
so yeah i see what you're saying there
so so even though you said
todd had just a rough outline of the of
the first scene or or
first act or whatever for the most part
if you were to do
let's suppose you wrote it from scratch
and and it was just completely your idea
you would have just done
this sort of illustrious bachelor
finally finds the one
and then you know
filling in there's a wedding there's a
kid shows up but then this road trip
movie maybe you wouldn't i and i don't
know how it ends
so you would kind of leave that last
right scene or scenes
yeah and i think that one of the things
i did in particular for
for that script was you know we knew
that they were going to have to
go and visit all these different women
along the road as they get to know each
other and they their develop their their
relationship develops
um so i didn't right away i didn't say
okay
they're going to meet this kind of
person they're that kind of person etc
and
what was really interesting is two
like two or three days before we
started shooting like two or three days
before principal photography
right um it might have been maybe a
little more than that might have been
like a week
but john asher came to me and he said
i need a scene for
marissa where it ha i want
i need her to be a really strong woman
character because we have a lot of
kind of crazy characters that that they
meet because it's a comedy
you know all right um and uh
so basically i i had to come up with a
whole new scene
right before we we made the made the
movie
and so you know i think we i don't
remember if we if we added her if we
pulled
one that was the one that was existing i
mean though those
those women went through all kinds of
changes as we went along
in the original script uh arden marine
who is
just a brilliant comedian um
her character um and in the original
script
was uh the the the stereotypical crazy
cat lady
who they show up at her house and she
has just
dozens of cats everywhere right and
what's wrong with that fabular has a
little tiny dog that he's hiding in his
you know in his shirt basically and of
course at some point the dog
jumps out of his shirt and all the cats
go crazy and then everything just goes
to chaos it was going to be a very big
sort of slap sticky scene
um unfortunately number one
um the budget wouldn't allow
for us to have dozens and dozens of cats
which are
you know the expression herding cats
well that's what you'd be doing
at the time right even if you see if you
use cg to put in a whole bunch of them
it would still i mean it would still be
um not cost effective let's say
um and plus the fact that
uh john asher myself and titus burgess
were all
very allergic to cats so you know that
was going to be a problem
so john asher actually came up with it
with an alternative idea which was
rather than her have rather than her be
a crazy cat lady
that she's just sort of this crazy
mannequin lady
and so we filled her house her house is
filled with all these mannequins who are
all dressed up
in clothes and she refers to them as if
they're real
you know real people oh wow and uh
and that ended up working
i don't know i don't say if it was would
work better because we don't know how
the cat scene would have worked out but
but it worked it worked to accomplish
what that scene needed to accomplish
um john came up with a couple of good
ideas that um
uh several in fact that you know some of
them were due
were because of the budget like i you
know when i
when you write a set piece for a scene
you always want to write it big
because it's you know it's it's usually
easier to cut it down than to build up
right so start big and then go small you
know right
um and so sometimes sometimes you have
to make adjustments just because your
budget is not going to be able to handle
that set piece
and um and john john um is a is a great
director but he's also he's been in the
business his whole life because of his
dad and so he understands
um you know what is what we're capable
of doing with a certain amount of money
and
what we're not capable of doing so he he
made adjustments to the script
by the way there's something else that
you know the director always gets the
final
uh pass on the script um
so so i i might write 12 13 drafts
in the end the one that we're going to
shoot is the one that he does the pass
on
and that's because he's the boss oh sure
did you two meet together though in
terms of going over logistics or
different things and he wanted your
input or is that something that's not
necessarily
um we went there was a little bit of
back and forth not much
um where he uh he
sent me he did a pass on it and he sent
it to me
and he asked what i thought and i was
terrified to read it
i was so afraid because i've had movies
made
where the director tossed my all my
dialogue
and put in horrible exposition you know
nightmare dialogue and
i had no control over that you know and
so i was
a little nervous even though i i liked
john escher immediately when i met him
and i
had you know faith that he was going to
do a good job
i still he sent me that version i
started reading it i was just
i was really okay here we go you know
but as it turns out the i would say
probably
75 to 80 percent of the the script was
still mine
that he made changes that he needed to
make um
uh and i and i know that i also know
that john landis
uh and john sat down earlier on and went
without me
and went through the script page by page
line by line
and john landis being the director of
some of the greatest comedies of all
time
basically said the ones that he thought
worked and what he thought didn't work
so it's a team process for sure
did you get to see the final edit before
the premiere
or was that okay so it wasn't like you
were walking into this premiere
no actually it was like again this is
and this is not the norm
this is definitely not the norm but i
will i was invited
to go to the uh the sound mix the final
sound mix
so i got to sit there with with todd and
with john landis and with
john and the producers and um they
actually
um asked my input of what i thought and
i john landis laughed because i at one
point um
i think todd said frank what do you
think and i said well i said well
i'm the writer as long as i can hear my
dialogue i'm good
[Laughter]
landis landis said i think glenda said
yeah spoken like a true writer
what a cool experience fantastic yeah it
sounds like a really like
a dream come true not just just seeing
it kind of come to life
and the different parts but also being
included and that was that's really what
made it
special because like i said i had i've
had other movies made before
you know most of the time it's a set
visit
uh or not at all i mean the second movie
that i had made was
shot entirely in uh south africa and you
know they don't bring the writer
along to do something like that so um
so this was this was a very unique uh
opportunity
um as a screenwriter um
and and it was nice it was it was very
nice and
um i just i made great friends
um you know with with those people we're
all still in touch
you